you can be a good Christian and actively
support the full official Democratic
party
platform yeah it's no possibility it's
not possible really just abortion just
abortion you cannot I mean I think
virtually every self-identified
Christian is on board with this but also
if you're Catholic the popes have been
pretty clear I just don't understand how
you can call yourself an actual
Christian I can understand almost
anything else like you know it's but you
know you're killing babies you're
killing babies I mean it's it's a the
right to life is not just one right
among many it is it is the prerequisite
prere for all the other yeah but all the
other stuff too I mean even the trans
stuff that is that on the platform I
guess it is these days probably I think
these days you know they're going to
build an idol to uh Osama Bin Laden soon
enough well not only that they may uh
they may actually be like worshiping
Satan they actually do worship s you
know what I'm saying yeah that's the
thing a little a little tough to include
that in your Christian liturgy